dear fellow scholars we have some
delightful news Elon Musk and Sam Altman
founded a non-profit artificial
intelligence research company that they
call open AI the founders have committed
over 1 billion dollars for this cause
their goal is to make progress towards
super intelligence leveraging their non
profit nature to make sure that such a
breakthrough will be done in a
controlled and beneficial way as of the
current state of things most of the
bigger companies with strong AI groups
publish their work regularly but as we
get closer to artificial general
intelligence and super intelligence it
is a question how much they will share
we have talked already about how
enormous lis powerful a super
intelligence could become and how
important it is to make sure that it is
developed in a safe way make sure to
check that video out a link is in the
description box it is really
mind-blowing so everything they create
will be open therefore the first
question that came to my mind is it
really good that anyone will be able to
create an AI what about users who are
interested in doing it in a way that is
harmful and dangerous to others this was
subject to a lot of debate and one of
the conclusions is that at the same time
most people are sensible and they expect
that the number of friendly AIS will
overpower the bad guys we don't know if
it's the best case scenario but it is
definitely better than the case of one
company owning the only super
intelligence at open AI they already
have researchers of their own and their
research projects will be completely
open this is amazing
because it rarely happens with companies
as they usually want to retain the
intellectual property of their projects
Amazon Web Services are also donating a
huge amount of resources for the company
the fact that just like at research
institutions the researchers can
publicly share their work may be a big
deciding factor when recruiting which is
according to the founders already going
really well so delightful news indeed
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
you